Hello, everyone.
My name is Thomas and
thanks for tuning in today.
So today we are
talking about
a client portal that we've
built for a customer of ours
in the Netherlands
where we used R Shiny with
embedded Power BI reports.
And I practiced my
presentation beforehand
for some friends
in Belgium, which
do not work in the IT sector.
And I didn't understand
a little thing.
So hopefully you will
understand something.
So we are Thomas and Joran, both working
for the IT company, AXI.
And, we traveled all the way
from Belgium, especially
for you today.
Yeah.
AXI is a full certified
partner from RStudio since 2020
and has a sector
specific approach.
If there are any questions
during the presentation,
you can always ask,
through Slido
or you can find us at
the stand next door
and have a little chat
and coffee with us.
So what can you expect
during your talk?
Some insights.
Why? It's not always Power BI
or Shiny, but sometimes Power BI
and R Shiny.
We are going to present some
examples of the use of R
Shiny in production.
And we have also some code
samples for you and of course
some references to a
famous man in bow tie.
So why are we
speaking here today?
Six months ago, Rachael
Dempsey from RStudio
at an online session with
Paul Cheng from Microsoft
about capacity planning for
Microsoft Azure data centers.
And my colleague Thomas
commented on the session,
if Paul had ever considered
about embedding Power BI
dashboards with R Shiny
in combination with Azure
functions that we
have used for plumber APIs
and Paul had never seen this
before, so Rachael replied
on that, like, I think that's
a great presentation too,
and that's why we
are here today.
So the customer with what
we realize this project
is a Dutch Mortgage Portfolio
Management Group, or DMPM,
and DMPM is part of the
Blauwtrust Group that
are a group of company that
provide mortgage lending
services together with the
entire mortgage value chain.
And as an organization, they can
offer institutional investors
to invest in Dutch
residential mortgages.
DMPM offers portfolio
management services,
including providing access to
an online interactive dashboard
called the mortgage
management tool.
And on the slide, you
can see some references.
Yeah, some customers
served by DMPM that
are famous banks in Europe.
So as promised, I
was going to tell
you more about how the
portal was before we started.
So at DMPM,
customers could consult
their insights of their
portfolio through the classical
BI approach.
Using Qlik, they
could log in and they
can save their bookmarks and
filter with custom filters.
But however,
these reports
were separate from
the DMPM websites
and were not customized, so
DMPM has not full ownership
of the portal.
So DMPM wants to evolve
their portal to a serious data
science portal, and they want
to provide their customers
with richer data and insights.
So this new portal
had some requirements
like rendering tailor
documents, including forecasts
on time series, still
providing classical dashboards,
but leveraging a new Azure
data platform with Power BI.
They want because they like
to work in a customer-oriented
way,
they want full control of the
look and feel and the user
experience, and they
also want to keep
ownership of the portal.
And of course, the portal
needs to be future proofed.
So R Shiny is often
thought as a dashboarding tool
and it plays the categories
like Power BI or Tableau.
But R Shiny is more than that.
Shiny can be used for
data science applications,
including dashboards, full-stack
web development and real-time
prediction applications.
As you can see from
the graph, R Shiny
has a very strong business
capability rating,
but the learning curve
is a bit more difficult
than a Power BI or a Tableau.
Since R is an
open source language,
there are several
packages available
and together with DMPM we
have chosen for R Markdown,
Shiny, and plumber.
This allowed us to create
interactive web applications
and by using R Markdown we were
able to generate our tailor
documents like a PDF.
We used plumber to separate the
logic in different functions.
In every project you encounter
different challenges.
So we had some challenges on
BI and data science level,
but also on Azure level.
Can you combine BI
tools with data science
solutions? Should we
combine Power BI or Shiny
or redevelop in pure R?
How we can embed a Power BI
dashboard?
Did we manage it?
Yes, we did.
But my colleague Joran DeWilde will tell
more in detail how we did it.
Thank you, Thomas.
Um, so when looking at the
already existing integrations
between the more
common BI tools and R,
we see that there are
actually a lot of options.
Uh, first of all, it's easy
to use an R or Python script
in your data preparation.
Use custom visuals
within your BI tools
that originate from
R or Python, or even
use a plumber API
to, for instance,
embed a forecast of your data.
So integrating R in your BI
tools isn't that difficult.
The other way around, however,
can pose some challenges.
Typically, the only
way to integrate a BI tool
into your R data
products is by
embedding it.
When looking at the
integration capabilities of Tableau
and R, for instance, we see
two major packages,
shinytableau and
plumbertableau.
Shiny tableau
being used for using
Shiny in your Tableau
dashboards and plumbertableau,
you can use an API
written in R in your
Tableau calculated fields.
Power BI also offers quite some
R integrations.
For instance, it's very
easy to get your data
using an R scripts or to
use R-powered visuals
in your Power BI dashboards.
So with these two
examples, I think
it's quite clear that using R
in your more common BI tools
is quite straightforward.
The other way around, however,
that's another question.
For instance, how
would you and this is also
the topic of the talk embed
a Power BI dashboard in your R Shiny
application.
If you want to use
a dashboard that
was written in Power BI
in an R Shiny application,
the first question that arised
for us was whether or not we should.
We could also just migrate the
existing visuals to our R Shiny
application. This way, Power BI
serves more as a design tool
where we kind of see what
works and what doesn't, and
the final visuals are recreated
in our R Shiny application.
This is an interesting approach.
If you have dashboards
that don't evolve a lot,
that don't change
a lot, and you have
people who feel comfortable
working in R and Shiny.
The option of embedding
is more interesting
if you have dashboards
that do change and evolve
a lot, this way you can
update your dashboards
without having to republish
your app every time.
Furthermore, you can
have a team that's
really dedicated to maintaining
the Power BI dashboards
who don't need to have
any Shiny knowledge.
For our case, we were definitely
in this second category
where we had a team of
people who didn't necessarily
possess the correct
amount of Shiny knowledge.
And we had dashboards that
changed and evolved a lot.
But how does embedding a
Power BI dashboard work exactly?
Well, the first thing we
do is write the application
and the general structure of
the application itself in Shiny.
Next, we use our Power BI and
its drag and drop features
to create a nice
looking dashboard.
And thereafter we simply
embed the dashboard
via nice and clean way
into our app this way
we get a portal that, thanks
to a unified UX and style,
it's very difficult
for the customers
to notice where your Power
BI dashboard ends and the R Shiny
application begins.
Of course, to be able to
embed a Power BI dashboard,
you'll need a few things.
First of all, of course, the
Power BI desktop software,
because with this
software you'll
be creating your
Power BI dashboards.
You'll also definitely
need the Power BI Service
because after all, that
is where your reports
will be published to.
With the Power BI Service,
you could technically
embed your Power BI dashboards
already using iFrames.
However, if you want to embed
it using the Power BI API,
you'll also need Power
BI Dedicated Capacity,
which you can either get via
Power BI Premium or Power BI
Embedded.
Keep in mind, however,
that this option will
be a bit more pricey, but
I hope to convince you
in the next slide why
this extra cost actually
might be worth it.
So the easiest solution
is using iFrames
to embed your Power BI dashboard.
However, this comes with
some very big disadvantages.
First, you'll have
to authenticate again
in each iFrame, which means
that the customer will
have to log in for each
dashboard that it wants to see.
And there are also no
interactions possible
between your Power BI dashboard
and your Shiny app.
These disadvantages are
negated by using API embedding,
because thanks
to the Power BI API,
you can integrate an automatic
authentication.
And with the API, you can also
catch all the interactions,
which means that you can
actually have your R Shiny
app communicate with your
Power BI dashboard, this way
you can create bookmarks,
apply and delete filters,
and, and many, many,
many more options.
But how does one embed
a Power BI dashboard
into an R Shiny app,
you may ask?
Well, fortunately
for us, Microsoft
offers a lot of examples on
how to embed a Power BI dashboard
using the API.
Unfortunately, however,
there is no clear example
of how to do it using
R Shiny.
Lucky for us, and probably
unlucky for others,
there's JavaScript to the rescue
via the Power BI JavaScript
library.
You can actually embed a Power
BI dashboard using JavaScript.
This means that
your R Shiny app
and the JavaScript
files will have
to communicate with each other.
On the R Shiny website, there's
already a very nice overview
of how to set up the
interactions between your R
and your JavaScript.
A brief overview.
So, sendCustomMessage can
be used in your R application
to trigger JavaScript
functions or JavaScript code.
These triggers can
be read and code
using the addCustomMessageHandler
in your JavaScript
files and to send input
back from your JavaScript
to your Shiny application,
The Shiny.onInputChange
button can be used.
A quick example of how we use
these functions in our app.
So when a user navigates
in your R Shiny app
to a page where there should
be a Power BI dashboard,
we will call the
sendCustomMessage
function, which will call the
EmbedApi function in your JavaScript
files.
With this custom message
we'll also send some
parameters for our report.
Next the powerbi-embed.js
JavaScript file,
the addCustomMessageHandler
will catch this callEmbedApi
and using some magic JavaScript
code
and using the
library, we can
embed the Power BI
dashboards
at a specific container
in our R Shiny app.
When it's done
rendering, we will
let our app know
that a report
has been rendered by using
the setInputValue and our
R Shiny app can continue
with its next step or steps
in the process.
To realize the authentication
and the more complex
interactions, some more complex
embedding steps were needed.
We won't go into too much
detail in this talk,
but I can share with you
already the tip of the embedding
iceberg.
For authentication, we
use the AzureAuth package.
This together with
the httr package
for retrieving the
embed token, made
it possible to integrate the
anticipation within our Shiny
app.
So no more two
different
authentication is necessary.
The Power BI API
was then
used to create bookmarks
to apply and delete filters
and so on and so on.
I want to conclude with
a brief overview of how
to embed a Power BI dashboard
into a Shiny app. For everyone
just tuning in,
this is probably one
of the most important
slides of our talk.
So we start by getting an
access token via Azure.
With this access token,
we can get the embed URL
from the Power BI API.
And with this URL together
with Javascript,
we can render our Power BI reports
in a container in our app.
Keep in mind, however, that
you will need Power BI Embedded
Capacity for this to work.
Now for the closing
thoughts of this talk,
I want to give
the spotlight back
to my colleague, Thomas.
So what lessons have
we learned today?
Align your Power BI
style and your layout
within your Shiny app.
If you can't see where the Shiny
ends and
your Power BI begins,
you are doing it right.
Be mindful and aware
of some cloud costs
and add logging where you can.
Shiny can log Power BI
actions as well.
So at the start of the
presentation, I mentioned this,
those were the check marks.
But did we cover them all?
We covered some of
debunking choices.
We have seen some examples
of Shiny in production.
You can
find our code samples
via the link on the
slide where
you can find step by
step documents
created with Quarto.
And, but we didn't cover
a reference to a famous
man in a bow tie.
So, without further
ado, that's all, folks.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you, everybody.
Any questions from the audience?
If not, I will
read off of Slido.
All right.
For Thomas and
Joran, why did you
decide to integrate
BI for the portal
into Shiny instead of the
other way around? At my org,
the audience for BI is bigger
than R!
So we think
that, with using
R Shiny, you have a lot
more options than just staying
in Power BI, which is why
we chose to actually do it
this way.
It's also a very
interesting concept
to embed a Power BI
dashboard in
Shiny app.
And Shiny offers way
more options and customizability
than Power BI.
You're not stuck in
the logic of Power BI.
You have
more freedom
which is also what
the customer wanted.
So we, we chose for
this way of working.
OK, we have time for more.
So, how did you
ensure both Power BI and Shiny
use the same data?
That's a very
interesting question,
which I don't have
the answer to right now.
But yeah, definitely
come get us at our booth.
And we can discuss
this in finer detail.
Any questions from the audience?
I've got one more on Slido.
All right.
Do you know if other BI
tools like Tableau
have API-driven authentication
like Power BI does?
Could you repeat the question?
Absolutely. Do you know if other
BI tools like Tableau
have API-driven authentication
like Power BI does?
So, we believe that the same
setup could actually also
be achieved
with Tableau.
Tableau also has an API for embedding.
However, we chose for
Power BI in this case
because our customer was
already heavily relying
on the Microsoft stack, which
made it an obvious choice
to choose Power BI to embed.
But it is also possible
with the Tableau API.